The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: So what
I wanted to do today
was talk about thermal
properties of foams.
And foams are often used
for thermal insulation.
And that's always
closed cell foams
that are used for
thermal insulation.
And we'll see why.
And the foams tend to have
a low thermal conductivity.
And that's largely because
gases have lower conductivity
than solids.
And if you have
mostly gas, you're
going to have a
lower conductivity.
So they have a low conductivity
because they have a high volume
fraction of gas.
And they've got a low volume
fraction of the solid.
They also have cells.
And the heat is
transferred partly
by radiation and convection.
And if you have small
cells, you reduce the amount
of convection and radiation.
And we'll see that.
So that, by having a
cellular structure,
and in particular, by
having small cells,
you can decrease
the heat transfer.
OK, so let me write
some of the stuff down.
So closed cell foams are widely
used for thermal insulation.
And the only materials with
lower thermal conductivity
than closed cell foams
are aerogels gels.
And I'll I talk
a little bit more
about aerogels later on today.
But the difficulty
with aerogels is
that they tend to be very weak
and brittle, like ridiculously
weak and brittle.
So we had a project on
aerogels a couple of years ago.
And the students who I
was collaborating with
would make aerogels.
And they'd bring
it up to my office.
And I would pick it up and
like-- I would pick it up
like this, and it would break.
So they have very low
thermal conductivity,
but they're very brittle.
And I brought a few of
our samples of aerogels,
just so you can see
what they look like.
And I'll pass them around
in that little tube,
so you can kind
of play with them.
OK, so we're going
to focus on foams.
And whoops-- And we can say
the low thermal conductivity
of foam arises mostly from the
high volume fraction of gas
and that the gas
has a low lambda,
a low thermal conductivity.
So lambda is thermal
conductivity,
so I'm just going
to put lambda there.
Then it has a small
volume fraction
of solid, which has a
higher thermal conductivity.
And then the foams have a
relatively small cell size.
So one of the things
we're going to look at
is how does the cell size
effect the thermal transfer,
the thermal conductivity.
OK, so there's lots of
applications for foams.
And I guess one of the
main ones is in buildings,
insulating buildings--
also insulating
refrigerated vehicles,
things like LNG tankers.
So there's lots of the
applications for using foams
for thermal insulation.
Foams, in addition to having
a low thermal conductivity,
they also have good
thermal shock resistance.
So thermal shock is if you have
a material, you heat it up,
and then you suddenly cool the
surface of it, for example.
So say you takes something
and you quench it in water
or quench it in some
fluid, then the surface,
it wants to shrink because
its temperature drops,
but it's connected to
everything underneath it
and it can't really shrink.
And so it's constrained and you
can get cracking and spalling.
And so, it turns out foams
have a good resistance
to that thermal shock
kind of loading.
And we'll see why that is, too.
Roughly, you can see if
the thermal expansion
strain is the thermal expansion
coefficient times the change
in temperature.
And the stress that
you might generate
is just going to be related to
the modulus times alpha times
delta-t.
And because we're going to
see that alpha for the foam
is the same as alpha
for the solid, but the E
foam is going to be a lot less
that E of a solid would be.
So because the
modulus is smaller,
you would get a better
thermal shock resistance.
OK, so I wanted to go
over a couple of sort
of laws of heat
conduction, so we
can talk about what
thermal conductivity is
and how we define it.
So the first one here--
--first one here is for
steady state conduction.
So when we say steady state
conduction, what we mean
is that the temperature
is constant with time,
the temperature doesn't
change with time.
So time's not going to come
into the equation here.
And heat transfer for
steady state conduction,
where there is no change in
the temperature with time,
described by Fourier's Law.
And that says that
the heat flux q
is equal to minus lambda times
the gradient in temperature.
And if you want to think about
just a one diversion of that,
it's equal to minus
lambda times dt by dx.
So here, q is our heat flux.
So that would have
units of joules
per meter squared per second.
So how much heat transfer
per unit area per unit time.
Lambda is the
thermal conductivity.
And it has units of watts per
meter k, so degrees kelvin.
And then delta
or-- and then this
is our temperature gradient.
OK, so that's Fourier's
Law, and we're
going to use that later on
when we talk about the foams.
And then, just so that we have
things a little more complete,
if you have a non-steady heat
conduction, if the temperature
varies with time, then
there's a difference equation
that involves the
thermal diffusivity.
So if we have non-steady
heat conduction-- so t
varies with time.
I'm going to call a time tau.
Then a partial differentiation,
the partial derivative
of temperature with
respect to time
is equal to the
diffusivity, that's
given the symbol a, times
the second derivative
of temperature with
respect of distance,
so with respect x squared.
So here a is the
thermal diffusivity.
And it is equal to the
thermal conductivity
divided by the density and
divided by the specific heat.
So here, rho is the density
and cp is the specific heat.
The specific heat
is the heat required
to raise the temperature
of a unit mass
by the unit temperature.
And so, the density times cp is
the volumetric heat capacity.
It's how much energy
you would need
to raise a certain
volume by, say, 1 degree
k instead of a certain mass.
OK, so on the table
here, on the screen,
we have different materials.
And we have the thermal
conductivity lambda.
And we have the
thermal diffusivity, a.
And I guess I should
also say a has units
of meters squared per second.
So this table is arranged
in order of decreasing
thermal conductivity.
So here's copper at the
top, 384, watts per meter k.
Here's, you know,
different metals.
You've got aluminum.
Here's a couple of ceramics.
They're about a factor of
10 less than the metals.
Here's the polymers, another
factor of 10 less than that.
And here's some gases.
Air is about 0.025.
Carbon dioxide is
less than that.
Triclorofluoromethane,
which used
to be used as a gas
in foams because it's
got such low thermal
conductivity, is 0.008.
But it's no longer used because
it's a-- what you call it?
A fluorocarbon.
Anyway, it decreases
our ozone layer.
So they don't use that anymore.
Now here's some wood.
So that's one sort
of cellular solid.
And they're around 0.04--
something like that.
And here's a group
of polymer foams.
And they're a little over 0.025.
So if you think of--
if you had the gas,
air-- if the air was
the gas inside the foam,
0.025 is lambda for the gas.
So you're not going to
get lower than that.
And you have to use a low
conductivity gas to get these
values, like 0.025
here, 0.020, 0.017.
And then, hear some other sorts
of sort of mineral fibers,
glass foams, glass wools.
OK, so that's just a table so
that you have some data there.
All right?
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] --foams,
if they are closed cell,
with a different gas rate.
Because if they're open cell--
PROFESSOR: --Right.
The gas is going to--
STUDENT: --it would
just always be air.
PROFESSOR: It's going to go.
And in fact, one
of the difficulties
with using the lower
conductivity of any gases
is there's a phenomenon called
aging, that if, you know,
you've got your gas
inside your foam,
it's going to diffuse
out into the air.
And air's going to diffuse in.
So over time, the
thermal conductivity
tends to increase
because you're getting
air coming and the local--
conductivity gas going out.
But I think,
typically, that process
takes a number of years.
It doesn't happen in a week.
But if you're
designing a building
and want the building to
be there for 50 years,
it occurs faster than that.
So it's not ideal from
that point of view.
All right.
So let me talk a little bit
more about thermal diffusivity.
Let me scoot over here.
So materials with a high value
of that thermal diffusivity, a.
They rapidly adjust
their temperature
to their surroundings.
So if they have a high
value of a, what it really
means they've got
a, say, a high value
of lamda-- so high
thermal conductivity.
And, say, a low value of this
volumetric heat capacity.
So it doesn't take much energy
to change their temperature.
And they also conduct heat well.
So they tend to adjust
their temperature
to their surroundings quickly.
OK, so then, let's talk about
the thermal conductivity
of a foam.
So I'm going to call
that lambda star.
So the star is the foam.
And then we'll
talk about-- lambda
s will be the lambda for the
solid that it's made from.
So if you think of the thermal
conductivity of the foam,
there's contributions
from different types
of heat transfer.
So you could have conduction
through the solid.
I'm going to call that lambda s.
You could have conduction
through the gas.
You could have convection
within the cell.
So convection has to do with
having, say, within the cell,
it might be a different
temperature on one
side of the cell to the
other side of the cell.
And the warmer side
of the cell, the gas
is going to tend to
rise to the warmer side
and fall to the cooler side.
And you get a convection
current set up.
So you can get heat
transfer from that.
And you can also get heat
transfer by radiation.
So radiation can cause
heat transfer, as well.
So we're going to have
contributions from conduction
through the solid.
So the amount of conduction in
the foam from the solid-- I'm
going to call lambda star s.
So lambda s would be the
conductivity of the solid.
And lambda star s is the thermal
conductivity contribution
from the solid in the foam.
So we get kind of--
through the solid.
We have conductivity
through the gas.
So it's lambda star g for gas.
And then we could have
convection within the cells.
We'll call that lambda star c.
And then we could get radiation
through the cell walls
and across the voids.
We'll call that lambda star r.
And so, the thermal
conductivity of the foam
is just the sum of those
four contributions.
So we're just going
to go through each
of those contributions,
in turn, and work out
how much thermal conductivity
you get from each of them.
And it turns out most of
the thermal conductivity
comes through the gas.
So if we first look at just
conduction through the solid,
we've got that contribution to
the conductivity of the foam
from the solid, it's just
equal to some efficiency factor
times the thermal conductivity
of the solid times
the volume fraction of the
solid or the relative density.
And here, eta is an
efficiency factor.
And it accounts for that
tortuosity in the foam.
So if you think of
the solid in the foam,
it's not like we have
little fibers that
just go from one side
to the other like this
and the heat just moves
along those fibers.
You know, the foam cells have
some complicated geometry
and the heat has to
kind of run along
that complicated geometry.
And people have made
estimates of what this is.
And it's roughly
a factor of 2/3.
So I guess it would depend on
exactly the foam cell geometry.
But typically it's around 2/3.
So that's conduction
through a solid.
That's straight forward.
Conduction through gas is
similarly straightforward.
It's just the
conductivity of the gas
times the amount of the gas.
And the volume fraction
of the gas is just 1
minus the volume
fraction of the solid.
So it's just 1 minus
the relative density.
So the conduction
through the gas
is just lambda g times 1
minus the relative density.
So we can do a
little example here.
And you can see how
much of the conduction
comes from the solid in the gas.
So for example, if we look at a
foam that's 2.5% dense and say
it's a closed cell poly-- what
are we doing-- polystyrene.
So the total thermal
conductivity of the foam
is about 0.04 watts per meter k.
And the thermal
conductivity of polystyrene
is 0.15 watts per meter k.
And the thermal conductivity
of air is 0.025.
So let's assume it's
just blown with air.
And then if I just
add up, what's
the contribution of
conduction through the solid
and conduction through
the gas-- so I just
use those two little
equations-- conduction
through the solid--
it's going to be 2/3
of this value of lambda s times
the amount of the solids--
that's 0.025 and then
plus lambda g, which
is 0.025 times the amount
of the gas, which is 0.975.
And if I work those two
things out, this is 0.003
and this is 0.024.
So that total is 0.027
watts per meter k.
So you can see if the
total is 0.04, most of it's
come from the gas.
A little bit's come
from the solid.
And the rest is going to be
from convection and radiation.
And that's typical.
And that's the reason
that they sometimes
use low thermal conductivity
gases to blow foams
for thermal insulation
because the gas makes up
such a big fraction of
the total conductivity.
If you can reduce
that, you reduce
the overall conductivity.
So, we'll say foams for
insulation are blown
with low conductivity gases.
But as I mentioned, you
have this problem with aging
that, over time, that gas
is going to diffuse out
and air is going to diffuse in.
Then the overall thermal
conductivity of the foam
is going to increase.
So that's the conduction.
And then the next contribution
is from convection.
So imagine we have one
of our little cells here.
And it's hotter on that side
than it is on that side.
And hot air is going to rise.
Cold air is going to fall.
So you get a convection
current set up.
And because of the
density changes,
you get a buoyancy
force in the air.
So that's kind of
driving the convection.
But you also have
a viscous drag.
So the air is moving past
the wall of the foam.
And there's going to be some
viscous drag associated.
And how much
convection you can get
depends on the balance
between this buoyancy force
and the viscous drag.
So we'll say the
gas rises and falls
due to density changes
with temperature.
And the density changes give
rise to buoyancy forces.
But we also have
these viscous forces
from the drag of the air
against the walls of the cell.
So air moving past
the walls-- this
is kind of a fluid mechanics
thing-- so that air is a fluid.
And in fluid
mechanics, they often
use dimensionless numbers.
And there's a
dimensionless number
called the Rayleigh number.
And the Rayleigh number,
you can think of it--
it's not quite the balance
of the buoyancy force
against the viscous forces.
But it involves those forces.
And convection is important
if this Raleigh number's
over 1,000.
And here's what the
Rayleigh number is.
It's the density of the
fluid times the acceleration
of gravity times beta.
Beta's the volume
expansion coefficient
for the gas-- times
the temperature change.
And we're going to
look at a temperature
change across a cell.
And then, times the length.
That's going to
be the cell size.
And we divide that by
the fluid viscosity
and the thermal diffusivity.
So let me write down what
all these things are.
So rho is the
density of the gas.
So the g's gravitational
acceleration.
Beta is the volume
expansion of the gas.
And for a constant
pressure that's
equal to 1 over the temperature.
Then delta tc is the temperature
difference across a cell.
And l is the cell size.
Mu is the dynamics
viscosity the fluid.
And a is our
thermal diffusivity.
So what I'm going to
do is just work out,
for a typical example,
how big of a cell size
do you need to get this
Rayleigh number to be 1,000.
And we're going to
see that, typically,
that cell size is big.
It's like 20 millimeters.
So in most foams,
the convection really
isn't very important at all.
So it's typically-- people
don't worry about convection.
And let me just show
you how that works.
So for our Rayleigh
number, which
is ra-- for the Rayleigh
number to be 1,000--
say we had air in the cells.
And say the temperature
was room temperature.
Then the volume coefficient
of expansion is just 1 over t.
So it's 1 over 300, say.
degrees k to the minus 1.
Let's say our change in
temperature across one cell
was 1 degree k.
Bless you.
The viscosity of air is 2
times 10 to the minus 5,
pascal seconds.
The density of air is 1.2
kilograms per cubic meter.
And the thermal
diffusivity for air
is 2 times 10 to the minus
5 meters squared per second.
And if you plug all of
these into that equation
for the Rayleigh number and
you solve for the cell size,
you find that the cell
size, l, is 20 millimeters.
So that says convection is
only important if the cell
size is bigger than that.
And so most foams have cells
much smaller than that.
And convection is negligible.
So I have enclosed
cells and the heat's
not transferred so easily
from one cell to another
by the gas moving.
And by having small cells
the convection drops out.
So you don't have
to worry about that.
So the last contribution to
heat transfer is from radiation.
And there's something
called Stefan's law
that describes the heat
flux for radiated heat
transfer from a surface
at one temperature
to another surface at
a different temperature
across a vacuum.
So we can say we
have a heat flux
qr not from a surface
of one temperature.
So I'm going to call that t1--
to one at a lower temperature.
I'm going to call tnot-- with
a vacuum in between them.
So this is [? Stefan's ?] law
so this is the radiative heat
flux is equal to the emissivity
of the surfaces, which
is beta 1 times
a constant called
Stefan's constant-- sigma
times the fourth power
of temperatures.
I'm taking the difference
of the temperatures
so here are the Stefan's
Constant-- is sigma.
And that's equal to 5.67
times the 10 to the minus 8.
And that's in watts per meter
squared per k to the fourth.
And beta is a
constant describing
the emissivity of the surfaces.
So it gives the
radiant heat flux
per unit area of the sample
relative to a black body.
And that's a characteristic
of the emissivity.
All right, so then,
so if we-- yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Now-- so right
now, forget the foam.
We have no foam.
We just have two surfaces
with a vacuum between them.
And now I'm going to stick
a foam between the surfaces.
And we're going to see how
that changes the heat flux, OK?
So the next step is we put
the foam between those two
surfaces.
And the heat flux is
going to be reduced
because the radiation is going
to be absorbed by the solid
and reflected by the cell walls.
And so we're going
to characterize
how much it's reduced.
So there's another law called
Beer's Law, which characterizes
the reduction in the heat flux.
Piece of chalk's
getting to small
OK, so Beer's Law gives us
the attenuation, so the sort
of reduction in the heat flow.
So qr is equal to qr not.
That would be the heat flux,
if we just had the vacuum.
And then there's
an exponential law.
And it's the exponential
of minus k star t star.
And here, k stars in an
extinction coefficient
for the foam.
Talk a little bit more
about that in a minute.
and t star is just the
thickness of the foam.
And then this thing
is called Beer's Law.
So we have very thin
walls and struts.
And we're just going to consider
optically thin walls and struts
to make life easy.
Then we can say that, if
they're optically thin,
they're transparent
to radiation.
They're optically
thin if they're
less than about 10 microns.
Then this extinction
coefficient is just the amount
of solid times the extension
coefficient for the solids.
So it's just the relative
density times the extinction
coefficient for the solid.
OK, and then I can say,
the heat flux by radiation.
I can use two equations
to write that down now.
And then I'm going to
let them be equal to get
the thermal conductivity.
I can say qr is going equal
to lambda r times dt by dx.
So that's the Fourier's Law
that we started out with.
And then I've also
got the qr that I'm
going to get by combining the
Stefan's Law with the Beer's
Law up there.
So if I do that, I
get that qr is beta
1 times sigma times t1 to the
fourth minus t not the fourth.
So that's the qr not up
there from down there.
And then I've got an
exponential for the attenuation.
And instead of k star, I'm going
to put the relative density
of times ks.
and then I've got the thickness
of the foam, t star, as well.
OK, so that's qr, but that has
to equal lambda times dt by dx.
So I'm going to use
some approximations.
Here and I'm going to
end up with an expression
for the contribution
from radiation
to heat transfer in the foam.
Yeah?
STUDENT: So when you say
optically thin walls, where
t is less than 10
microns, you mean
like the walls of the foam?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yea.
STUDENT: So it's
different t than the--
PROFESSOR: t star
is the thickness
of the whole thing, yeah.
So imagine we had
our two surfaces.
And they might be like
100 millimeters apart
or something. t star is
the sort of thickness
of the foam in between
the two surfaces.
And the optically thin
is the cell walls, which
are microns kind of thickness.
OK.
So I'm going to make
some approximations here.
And that's going to allow
me to solve for t star.
So I'm going to
say that dt by dx
x is approximately
equal to just t1 minus t
not over the
thickness of the foam
or I'll call that
delta t over t star.
And then, the other
approximation I'm going to use
is that t1 to the 4th
minus t not to the fourth
is equal to 4
times delta t times
the average temperature cubed.
So here t bar is the average
temperature, t1 plus t
not over 2.
So then, if I use those
two approximations,
I can write that qr, our heat
flux from radiative transfer.
I got the beta 1.
I've got the sigma.
And instead of the difference
of the fourth power,
I'm going to write 4
delta t t bar cubed.
And then I've got
my exponential.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So then, here's the relative
density times ks times
t star, the overall thickness.
That's going to equal the
radiative contribution
to the thermal
conductivity of the foam.
And instead of dt
by dx, I'm going
to have delta t
over t star here.
So part of the reason
for doing these
approximations I end up with
a delta t term on both sides.
Now I can cancel that out.
And if I just take this mess
here and multiply it by t star,
then I've got lambda r star.
That's our thermal conductivity
contribution from radiation.
So one of the things
to notice here
is that, as the relative
density goes down,
then the contribution
from radiation
to the thermal conductivity
of the foam goes up.
OK, so this chart here
shows thermal conductivity
as a function of
relative density.
And it breaks down
the contributions
from the gas, g, the solid,
s, and the radiation, r.
And you kind of see
the gas contribution
doesn't change that much.
These are relative densities
between a little over 2
and a little less than 5%.
So the amount of
gas-- it's mostly
gas in all of these things.
The solid contribution increases
as the relative density
increases.
So you'd expect that.
And then, as I just said, as
the relative density goes down,
the amount of radiation
contribution goes up.
And so you can kind of see
how that all fits together.
Another plot that shows
the thermal conductivity
versus the relative density.
These are for a few
different types of foams.
You can see for
this plot here, you
reach a minimum in the
thermal conductivity.
And that's because
you've got this trade off
between the contribution from
the solid and the contribution
from the radiation.
And those two kind of trade
off and you get to a minimum.
So let me write
some of this down.
So I'll just say that-- hang on.
Write this over again.
This is looking at the
overall thermal conductivity.
And we can see the
relative contributions
of lambda, solid, lambda,
gas, lambda, radiation.
I'll just say this
shown in the figure.
I'm going to say the next
figure shows a minimum
in the thermal conductivity.
Then I'll just say
there's a trade off
between the conduction
through the solid
and I can direction
from the radiation.
And then we also
have a plot here
that shows the conductivity
versus the cell size.
And you can see that the
conductivity increases
with cell size.
And the reason for that is
the bigger the cells get,
the radiation is
reflected less often.
And one thing I wanted to
mention with the cell size
is that if you look at aerogels,
the way aerogels shells work
is that they have a very small
cell size, a very small pore
size.
So typically, it's less
than 100 nanometers.
And the mean free path
of air is 68 nanometers.
So the mean free path
is the average distance
the molecules move before they
collide with another molecule.
And if your pore size is
less than the mean free path,
then that reduces the
thermal conductivity.
It reduces the
ability of the atoms
to pass the heat along
between one another.
So the way the
aerogels work is they
have a very small pore size.
And what's important
is how big the pores
are relative to the
mean free path of air.
OK, so that's the
thermal conductivity.
I wanted to talk about a
few other thermal properties
of foams, as well, today.
So one is the specific heat.
And since the specific
heat is the energy required
to raise the temperature
by a unit mass,
then the mass is
the same-- you know,
if you have a
certain mass of foam
or a certain mass of solid--
the specific heat from the foam
is the same as the solid.
So the specific
heat for the foam
is the same as the specific
heat for the solid.
So that would have
units of joules
per kilogram per degree k.
And the next property is the
thermal expansion coefficient.
And it's a similar thing.
The thermal expansion
coefficient for the foam
is equal to the
thermal coefficient
of expansion for the solid.
So imagine you have-- say you
had something like a honeycomb.
If you heat it up
a certain amount,
every member is going
to expand by alpha.
And if every member
expands by alpha,
the whole thing
expands by alpha.
And this is the same.
And it's the same
idea with the foam.
So if every member just
gets longer by alpha,
then the whole thing
gets bigger by alpha.
OK, so the last topic
I wanted to talk about
was the thermal
shock resistance.
And thermal shock is the idea
is that if you have something
that's hot, and say you
quench it in a liquid--
so you put it
suddenly in a liquid--
the surface is
going to cool down
faster than the bulk of it.
And because the
surface is trying
to contract because
it's cooling down,
but it's attached to the bulk
of it and it's constrained,
it can't really cool down,
then you generate stresses.
And if the stresses
are big enough,
you can cause fracture and
have the thing crack and spall.
So we'll say if the
materials is subjected
to a sudden change in the
surface temperature, that
induces thermal
stresses at the surface
and can induce
spalling and cracking.
So we're going to think about
a material at one temperature
that's dropped
into, say, a liquid
at a different temperature.
So the surface
temperature is going
to drop to the cooler
liquid temperature
and it's going to contract
the surface layers.
And the fact that they're bound
to the layers underneath that
are not contracting
as quickly, it
means that you generate
a thermal strain.
So the thermal
strain is going to be
the coefficient of thermal
expansion times the change
in temperature.
So you're going to
constrain the surface
to the original dimensions.
And then you're going
to induce the stress.
So if it's a plane or
thing, it's e alpha delta t.
And then, there's a
factor of 1 minus nu,
just because it's a
plane, in a plane.
And then you'll get
cracking or spalling
when that stress equals
some failure, stress.
So I can rearrange this and
solve for the critical delta t
that you can withstand
without getting cracking.
So I just rearranged this and
say sigma's equal to sigma f.
That would be sigma f times 1
minus nu over e and over alpha.
So that's the critical
change in temperature
to just cause cracking.
So now what I can do is I can
substitute in there for what
you would have for the foam.
And I'm going to do it
just for the open cells
just because it's easier
to write the equations.
So for the foam, I would have
some sort of fracture strength.
So when we did the
modeling of the foams,
we said that was equal to
about 0.2 times the modulus
of rupture times the relative
density to the 3/2's power
and 1 minus nu.
And if I divide by the
modulus of the foam,
that's es times the
relative density squared.
And then we just had
alpha for the foam
was the same as alpha s.
So then, I can
rearrange this slightly
and say it's equal to 0.2
over the relative density
to the 1/2 power.
So I'm canceling out these
relative densities here.
And then I can combine all
the solid properties together.
And I'm going to say
that nu for the solid
is about equal to the
same as nu for the foam.
So what I can do here is I can
group all the solid properties
together.
And this just is delta t
critical for the solid, right?
So this is saying that the
critical temperature range
before you get
cracking in the foam
is equal to the
range for the solid,
but multiplied by
this factor of 0.2
and divided by the square
root of the relative density.
So if the square of--
the relative density
is going to less than 1.
So this number here is
going to be bigger than 1.
So it's saying that the
temperature range that
will give you
spalling in the foam
is going to be bigger than the
temperature range in the solid.
So the foam's going to be
better than the solid, OK?
And that uses our little
models from before.
So I think I'm going
to stop there, probably
cause my throat is
starting to get too sore.
There's a little case
study in the notes.
And I'll just put that on the
notes on the Stellar site.
It's like one page and it's
really straightforward.
You can just read that, OK?
So this is the end of the
bit on thermal conductivity.
That's just this one lecture.
And this is really the
end of the whole section
on modeling of the honey
combs and the foams.
So that's kind of the first
half of the term is modeling
the honey combs and the foams.
And the second half
of the term, we're
kind of applying those models
to different situations.
So next week, we'll have
the review on Monday,
have a test on Wednesday, week
after that is Spring break.
I can't believe we're
at Spring break already.
And then after that we'll
start we'll do the trabecular
bone for a week.
We'll do tissue engineering
scaffolds and cell mechanics
for two or three lectures.
We'll look at some
other applications
to engineering design, look at
energy absorption and sandwich
panels.
And then, I'm going to talk
about plants a little bit
at the very end, OK?
So we've already covered a
lot of the kind of deriving
equations part of the course.
The rest of the course is
more applying the equations
to lots of different
situations, OK?
So I'm going to stop there
just because my throat is
giving out.